[Musique]
dans les banlieues de la région
parisienne on trouve des bidonvilles où
vivent des portugaises ou des
yougoslaves taudis pour homme déraciné
qui voisinent avec les pavillons sans
histoire de fond c'est bien tranquille
entre eux plus violente que les fils
barbelés plus épaisse qu'un mur il y à
la haine
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez mis cette
pancarte
comment avez vous mis cette teinte car
j'ai passé ils démolissent la créature
magique a pas ce qui s'y passait
inaperçu avec
une fourche
et l'enfant qu'ils sont vos voisins
ensuite
tu étais déjà fait expulser par le
procureur de la république c'est tout
c'est étrange il ya des messageries
qu'elle est assez alors il n'a jamais
demandé s'il avait des problèmes pour se
loger
donc là dedans le
voulez vous loger la kangoo et quand on
les met dehors où vont-ils aller croyez
que ont envie de lâcher la yougoslave
des portuaires et à la
même heure en libye manul l'avion ils
sont tous suivis elle vaut mieux
assurent la clôture là ils dévalisent la
clôture en hausse et c'est pas drôle
mais si on les fait venir c'est pour
travailler c'est parce qu'on en a besoin
mais il coûte rien vous leur avez parlé
déjà au programme
non pas possible non
je ne les aimais vit en foyer comme ça
etc
[Musique]
15 rue buisson à paris dans le 20ème
arrondissement derrière un portail
rouillé cette cour où s'entassent les
poubelles est devenu un no man's land
d'un côté la rue les passants des cafés
les magasins l'ordre un monde bien élevé
qui attend observe s'inquiètent de
savoir ce qui se passe de l'autre côté
derrière les murs sales dans ce foyer où
vivent des noirs qui sont sortis de
notre oubli pour faire une grève dont on
parle dans les journaux
depuis plusieurs mois les locataires de
la rue buisson refuse de payer leur
loyer ils ne sont pas les seuls à
saint-denis rue du landy à montreuil
avenue léon gaumont rue riquet dans le
19e rue nordman dans le xiiième ailleurs
encore partout il ya des taudis
semblable à celui de la rue buisson mais
ils sont des dizaines les noirs
brusquement on dit non
non à la haine certes non racisme
évidemment dont ils sont les victimes
désignées eux qui ne peuvent cacher
qu'ils sont étrangers mais d'abord nous
à ce qui exige d'eux une caution de 210
francs pour avoir le droit de venir
vivre ici dans deux mètres carrés pour
un loyer de 70 francs par mois
diabira et le délégué des locataires de
la rue buisson
vous êtes combien dans cette chambre aux
actes at
ça fait quelque peu près combien de
places par personne alors ça en fait
la z4 lui je lis que possible mais pas
de talent mais pas de celle ci les
trains ir et
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme la requête m²
pour les personnes
de mètres carrés reconnaissable c'est
ici que vous mangez
pas de réfectoire et près du corps
et dans la cuisine il y a que 10 réchaud
pour les 400 pensionnaires du foyer de
la rue buisson dix petites flammes au
centre du foyer
à tour de rôle chacun vient y faire
cuire le riz le poulet ou les brochettes
dans cette caisse trop petit on retrouve
l'afrique des femmes viennent d'éplucher
les légumes on rit on transpire ans se
bousculent chaque gamme elle porte le
nom d'un village
[Musique]
mes amis qui venaient en france à avoir
jamais venu d'ici le français bien mais
moi j'ai mes pensées que mémé mes frères
sont cousines foyer que tout dit comme
ça pourquoi on est en face parce qu'on
n'est pas le boulot en mauritanie se
déroulera à l'afrique mais ce truc nous
a fait qu'elle vient pas en france au
fait que vous obtiendrez des faillites
correct
le ciel quoi et vous vivez ici depuis
longtemps mais pas francis vous allez
toujours vécu ici vous dans d'autres
foyers aussi annonce qui suscite
comment est-ce que ça se passe comment
vous vivez
vous travaillez enregistrerait où ce
sera le cas nous
vous pensez que vous pouvez pas vivre
ici dans des conditions qu'on reçoit
aucune importance
mais vous pensez que ça va changer
je pense pas je ne sais pas je pense pas
s'agir s'agira simplement traversé tant
de héros pour laisser moi
vous êtes le président vous de se
soigner
il ya combien de personnes ici à 400
personnes
est ce qu'on pensait que un noir qui
vient travailler ici
ne peut pas trouver un logement au point
que c'est difficile à trouver pour
mémoire
ne s'efface il pouvait blâmer c'est
difficile à trouver pour les noirs
vous ne pouvez rien faire contre ça
normal on ne pouvait pas faire il ya
parce qu'ils n'en avaient pas assez fort
ou le sage parce qu'il ne pas construire
les syndicats si les noirs
[Musique]
on parle l'avis des français mais qu'il
ya des français qui fument bien mais les
trois quarts sont des racistes
comme
moi parce qu'ils et j'y vais pas les
îles vais pas les noirs j'ai pas les
moeurs
qu'est ce qu'ils ne font pas ce qu'ils
vous disent oui ils disent tous parce qu
il quand un disque est tous un peu ils
disent que si vous n'êtes pas content
vous partez au pays
dans la cour du foyer il ya une usine à
y aller c'est noël vous les connaissez
les jambes cette usine dans l'eau est-ce
que des africains qui habitent ici et
qui travaillent dans cette usine
personnes
dans l'ensemble gagné combien c'est par
exemple dans les légendes s'il faille et
il ya à peu près le salaire on sait un
peu plus
afin vis 1,9 c'est un maximum 1000
francs par mois
vous envoyer de l'argent vos familles on
oblige à envoyer face à celui qui est
marié et qu'il laisse sa femme là bas ou
bien celui qui aimeriez qu'il ne se
souvient parents est obligé quand même
de l'envoyer
l'argent de quoi vivent
15 robinet d'eau froide alignés contre
un mur c'est ce que le propriétaire du
foyer appelle des douches
un poêle à mazout reste de l'ancienne
usine brûle sur le palier rue buisson un
incendie thurette 350 personnes
tous les jours mais ça ou touré quitte
évasion 2000 la tour du front de seine
où il s'est installé il ya moins d'un an
d'origine guinéenne monsieur touré 36
ans et depuis fort longtemps naturalisé
français l'élégant locataires du 15e
arrondissement et dans le xxème
florissant propriétaire gérant de deux
foyers ce marchand de sommeil quelques
900 locataire officiel ou clandestins
qui tous payent chaque mois un loyer de
50 70 ou 90 francs tu lui as iront ainsi
un revenu brut de plus de 60 mille
francs
dans la soute et moi j'aimerais à deux
foyers inquiets celui de la rémission de
la rue buisson est inquiet dans le xiiie
arrondissement
seulement nous faut de la réglisse ans
étaient envoyés et qu'on appelle dix ans
j'ai créé ce foyer pour isolement c'est
pour pouvoir sorti les arénas les gars
patinent d afrique et elle a habité dans
les caves mais il existe depuis six ans
précise seulement vous savez quand on
voyait des modèles qu'ils ont d'argent
tradition du prêt d'argent d'abord
financier même plus gourmands une
question que vous avez c'est un besoin
d'eux et qu'ils ont au moins il ya
combien de personnes rue buisson hoya il
ya deux cent quatre-vingt onze personnes
brison sans compter les clandestins
c'est à dire qu'il ya 400 personnes
n'ont ils pas 400 personnes ça dit moi
je compte qu'il faut conduire des avions
de toi fin et quelques personnes 350
personnes je ne dis pas que les
conditions ne sont pas sérieux mais qui
est à l'origine de la série tv loco
est ce monsieur touré avant 36 la
plupart des africains était dans le car
j'étais amené à visiter plus de foyers
dans ce cadre il y avait aucune espèce
d'aberration y avait simplement départ
moi je peux vous dire que nous fait de
la révision par rapport à ça car c'est
un chapeau
pourtant la rue bissau a aussi ses caves
transformée en chambre ou comme celle ci
en atelier de couture où l'on vient en
dehors de ses heures de travail faire
ses propres vêtements et en fabriquer
d'autres que l'on pourra vendre
[Musique]
et
tu
[Musique]
la semos que l'endroit confessions de la
prieure
monsieur touré scénique et de
responsables du tour et responsable tu
es responsable bibi sont mes deux
français voile quand même comment sont
les noirs à actuelle à paris comment
sont les noirs à la révolution connaît
actuellement comment ils sont logés
nounoune accuse tour et parce que touré
il est père et gérant de l'arbizon mais
pour le moment notre lutte c'est pas
simplement les tours ssrc aux hélicos
responsable pour le super pour nous pour
loger vous avez déposé une plainte
contre lui oui je crois que c'est ce
qu'il a fait
et vous pensez qu'elle va aboutir
ce mois
la justice a dans ce domaine tous les
moyens qu'elle peut souhaiter les lois
françaises sont sévères pour les
marchands de sommeil mais la justice ne
suffit pas il faut aussi d'autres
logements
je crois qu'on a droit à voir en foyer
qui est construit par le gouvernement
alors on attendait jusqu'à présent dans
la vie du premier
fait beaucoup de démarches bref beaucoup
de manchons l'été voire conseil
municipal que communiste 20e
arrondissement ont été voir le député
l'idée est requis et un terme à
l'enlisement
nous a promis beaucoup de choses
leurs promesses
personne jusqu'à présent n'a tenu ses
promesses malgré les efforts du
gouvernement
à chaque fois qu'un nouveau lieu est
prêt six nouveaux immigrants arrivent 1
pour 6 c'est le problème de joseph revol
en 1971 par exemple vous avez créé
combien de frayer en 1971 nous avons
financé 2000 à 2100 lits dans la région
parisienne pour les travailleurs
étrangers actuellement pour des chambres
à trois lits de loyer de l'ordre de 90
francs par mois mais cette formule des
chambres à trois lits devient une
formule un peu historique car nous nous
efforçons maintenant des finances et
surtout des foyers offrant des chambres
individuelles
la plupart des foyers qui sont
construits maintenant offre une vie
moderne confort moderne des chambres
individuelles mais ça ne répond pas un
esprit communautaire de tribal de tous
ces travailleurs africains qui sont
d'autant plus tenté de vivre en
communauté qu'ils sont déracinés et
qu'il se trouve dans un milieu
totalement différent ce qu'ils
connaissaient avant la sépaq
vivre comme ça parce qu'ils n'ont pas le
choix
ils n'ont pas le choix c'est vrai ils
n'ont pas le choix car ils mentent
encore malgré tous les efforts qui ont
été faits par rapport à public il manque
encore un certain nombre de foyers
notamment dans la ville de paris dans la
région parisienne qui permettrait de
résorber tous ces taudis
dans une autre cave de bissau lien
barques sont aménagés eux-mêmes 25
mètres carrés de liberté pour 400 âmes
soeurs
[Musique]
cette grève des loyers qui dure depuis
six mois et la première manifestation
collective des travailleurs immigrés
l'un de leurs représentants le dit elle
est aussi leur première prise de
conscience
un pipe à lui mais en france ça lui
coûte souvent 4 à 5000 à 6000 france
info qu'il paye à qui il pas il ya un
intermédiaire qui est un type
respectable comme on appelle ces nous
allah dit c'est lui qui sert
d'intermédiaire entre le candidat de
départ et les fonctionnaires que ce clip
de passeport que ce type de carte
d'identité des pieds qui s'occupe de
cars et de sanitaires et en plus avec de
police du port est en prise avec deux
marins de bord compris le commandant de
voir parce que les blessures laissées
clientèle c'est d'avoir des clients que
le gars soient refoulés ou tel qu'ils le
parti essentielle qu'il a des clients et
leur intérêt de l'enfant et ceux qui par
le reste c'est très rare qui sont dans
ses foyers qu'est ce qu'ils ont une
chance de s'en sortir
et la sas de s'en sortir je crois que
tout c'est notre travail
et pour que ce soit il faut qu'il ya une
révolution dans leur propre pays
parce que six 06 et constate la
situation en france que l'ensemble des
personnes qui s'occupent de ce problème
ils passent uniquement en fonction de
l'économie française
alors qu'il n'est pas à mes retours de
ces eaux là pourquoi y vient mais est-ce
qu en tirait toujours qu'est ce qu'ils
vont faire à la salle omnisports souffre
terriblement donc notre organisation qui
travaille dans ce sens que vous aurez
tous qu'il ya une révolution
parce que malheureusement on dit
toujours il faut faire une action non
violente mais nous vivons ça pue
l'europe manque de travailleurs elles
devront trouver 11 millions en dehors de
ses frontières d'ici à 1980
[Musique]